pourquoi ces les invite ses coups de
gueule ses collègues en a dix ans de
moins que retiendra le grand public y
professeur choron dire ça ne veut plus
rien dire lycéens
les maires de l'est soit censure dollars
le garderont l'image d'un professeur
chevreuse cofondateur avec adama d'hara
kiri et charlie hebdo police qui présage
cabu une bande vite que nos classes
qu'est devenue célèbre safir titre
provocateur démêlés avec la justice
jusqu'à l'interdiction du journal sans
1966 à la mort du général de gaulle le
journal devint alors le symbole de la
liberté d'expression muselée par la
censure or ce cadre on meurt aujourd'hui
que mon pardon je romps kavanagh ses 50
ans d'amitié et un esprit caustique
partager kavanagh en écrivant ce matin
son papier sur son ami pour charlie
hebdo préfère se souvenir de l'autre
visage du professeur choron
c'est vraiment une intelligence j'ai
fait presque un génie en friche ils ont
trop retient que ces coûts c'est qu'on
sait que vous et d'ivrognes facétieux je
vous espère tôt pour ça le professeur
choron alias georges bernier avait 75
ans
il est mort ce matin d'une leucémie